please welcome someone i actually know
and highly like and respect don russell
hello my friend oh darn i'm so happy to
see you
it's just so nice to see you now you
were diagnosed with
stage three cancer when you were 25
years old
how did you heal yourself how did you
change your eating habits your life
tell us the secrets yes when i was
25 i was diagnosed with stage three out
of stage four cancer and obviously
that's an incredibly
humbling moment and on my fourth surgery
i got a bone infection and that's really
when everything changed for me
um i couldn't do chemo or radiation and
so for years i set out
traveling the globe trying to find
treatments to compensate for the chemo
radiation the fascinating part is only
to end up back in my little apartment in
new york going to
the basics of food i learned firsthand
the power of greens
and then um i just really set out on a
mission of i've got to figure out a way
to help
everyone get greens in an easy way every
day so i spent
many years trying to solve that for
everyone
okay and then eight greens
was launched this simple tablet
and it's like been growing
ever since so tell everybody what they
get
in this tablet yes well that's exactly
it like there are no miracles you know
and i spent five years making this 264
prototypes because it had to taste good
we all know no matter how
much we know we need to eat something if
it doesn't taste good we're not going to
do it
then to get them in a daily usage of
spinach wheat grass
kale blue green algae spirulina
chlorella
and barley grass so that was my goal get
those greens
what you're it's beautiful but it's
slightly overwhelming isn't it like how
do you get that in your kids every day
i don't know but i love that you have
found these ways
and we're gonna show three healthy ways
that you can easily and deliciously
incorporate them in and then i'm going
to bonus it at the end
with an amazing recipe that none other
than gwyneth paltrow
promotes that's in your book for kids so
let's start here what have we got first
dawn
yes yes so first we have the um
we have the fruit cobbler so this recipe
literally
is to curb your sweet tooth you
basically have
all these fruits i have blueberry
raspberries peaches
um blackberries and you take coconut
sugar
and you literally pour that in the sugar
and then
you have a quarter of a cup of water
and as you were saying we have this
eight greens tablet
and that has the eight greens that we
discussed exactly you put it in the
water
it dissolves in the water yep and then
you just pour it on top of the fruit
as you're doing you stir it up the fruit
the coconut sugar the eight grains in
the water and then you pour it as the
base
in the dish
then you have your dry goods we already
have them done but it's
rolled oats flour we have some cinnamon
and you literally put that on top and so
you then you put it
in the oven exactly how you're doing it
for 400 degrees let it get really really
crispy on the top
and this is it done you can see it's the
the really nice part about it drew is
that it
gets there's moisture at the bottom
so it's tasty it's not dry
it's like yummy it's like a delicious
cobbler then next one we're doing the um
chia pudding
so you take one cup of coconut milk
then you take a little less just a
little bit less than a half a cup
of chia seed put these chia seeds
in the coconut milk as you're doing and
the most important thing is whisking it
like you're doing it
now whisk because that is going to bring
the texture
what you're doing and then literally
this is it you put it in the
refrigerator overnight
and the next day check this baby out
it is literally coconut milk and chia
seeds
and you can put some raspberries on it
you gotta try it drew that's right
it is like we have a dressed version
right here
can you believe how simple it is true
it's like painfully simple and
painfully good oh my god it's so good
okay now third and
third and final what's great is it's a
juice but it's a super easy one
and there's no sugar in it and it's
obviously super healthy so
basically you have half a cup of
pineapples
you have a half a cup of coconut water i
cannot say enough
about coconut water now this is where i
like to keep it super simple for
everyone
they say like you know x amount of
ginger literally
just cut three of these pieces literally
just
three of these in the blender and then
same thing
with with the mint stick just put the
whole
thing in the blender and you will get
voila you have the best fiber in here
and there is
literally don this is so incredible we
all want to be healthy but we all have
like no
time for it so my whole thing is how can
we do it super quickly be it from the
fruit cobbler or the
chia pudding uh gwyneth's um fish
fingers recipe
uh was one of the ones that turned me on
as a parent
that we could incorporate eight greens
into
food for our children because we're all
struggling to get greens into our kids
and so
if you go over to digital um obviously
i'm showing it right here on broadcast
but we're gonna do a little
expose on gwyneth and dawn's uh book
for the fish fingers and how you can get
greens into
your little ones and um
absolutely can i just tell you one quick
thing please
so you know we have the gummies which
are sweet and
literally tomorrow we are launching
chewables it is the world's first real
green chewable it's super sour it's for
your like candy sour fix
these are insane and guess what vff's
you're all getting a wellness bundle
filled with eight green
tablets gummies and the brand new
chewables
and an assortment of chickpea based
products from
bonza including their new line of pizza
and a variety of protein-packed
nutritious meal options
from kodiak cake thank you dawn for
coming today